like how would you feel if you went to
go hang out with jesus and he's always
on the phone
like talking to someone else you know
what i mean you kind of just feel like
oh
man i think that's kind of how our kids
would would feel if we are constantly
doing that to them
how well do you pay attention find out
on this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome everyone to another episode of
led live today
we are excited to be bringing a topic to
you about attention
and there's a few things in this show i
think that might surprise you
one of them i hope will surprise you
very well but we won't know
until the end so pay attention because
you don't want to miss it
um it seemed what was it
last year maybe the year before you did
a show called
mesmerized tell us about mesmerized
so it's kind of just like you know when
we look at the television and what's
actually going on inside the brain
it's very similar to the same brainwave
patterns as hypnosis um we
we experience the same sort of symptoms
that you do if you were hypnotized
um you your um ability to track
time is kind of gone your peripheral
vision is kind of gone and you sort of
zone out
so that's kind of what it was was really
getting to the bottom of
you know the hypnotism basically that
media can put us in
i thought that was a really fascinating
show that we did and there were several
social experiments in there that just
showed
how humans behave and and what it takes
to get us to do things i mean you've
seen people standing in lines for
they didn't even know why somebody
started a line and then
you know they were waiting around they
don't know what they were waiting around
you just put up a couple of props
or somebody sitting in a room and you
can get them to
stand up and sit down because everybody
else is doing it right
today we're going to talk a little bit
about the brain as well but we're going
to talk about it from
a slightly different focus it's going to
be from the
perspective of attention so i want to
ask you guys some questions
have you ever been distracted before
oh yeah okay yeah daily have you ever
had anybody tell you
you're not paying attention or you're
distracted or you're not hearing what
i'm saying
that's my wife yeah we have a we have a
phrase that uh
says like uh you know shiny object yeah
shiny object
it's it's easy to do and i i noticed
just the other day candy had started
asking me a question
and i could hear some of the words that
she was saying but because i was doing
something else
i knew i wasn't getting it and so i had
to like
stop what i was doing have her repeat
and say okay what was that and
really focus on what it is that she was
trying to tell me
so question for the audience do you know
what's going on
in the world around you and my
question to follow that up is how do you
how do you know
you believe you're making a conscious
effort to pay attention right now
but we live in a world where multiple
things demand our attention right
we're even creating things to demand
more of our attention
one of them is on the table in front of
scotty right
and we can't give our attention to
everything
it's simply not possible
so in reality we filter right we have to
that's what our brain does it filters
information that's coming at us all the
time
but history the news
uh different things social media
those things also filter do you listen
to fox do you listen to cnn yeah
that's a different filter so your brain
is filtering
what's already being filtered so you're
really only getting a fraction
of the entirety of information that's
available to you
you're only getting a small window
because you're further filtering out
that information
okay so looking at this article that i
pulled from the apa
it says this just as people intuitively
believe
that seeing something is a matter of
only opening the eyes
cognitive science also assume that
visual perception
is like a videotape that the mind
records what the eyes take in
it seems to make sense right but
increasingly studies of visual
perception have demonstrated
how startingly little people see
when we're not paying attention a
phenomenon known
as intentional blindness so now now
do they do this in like crimes when they
go and they interview witnesses and
stuff because sometimes they
they they really have a different view
based on like
yeah it's it's it's almost somewhat
amazing that we use
eyewitness accounts in court because
everything that i've read suggests that
eyewitness accounts are not reliable
because you have so many different
perspectives and because of things like
this like people
miss stuff they don't really you know
they think they see something that they
don't
so yeah this plays into a wide variety
of situations in life but what does it
mean to pay attention
because i'm sure every eyewitness would
say i was paying attention but yet
taking away their perspective their own
bias
you know they still miss things yeah
they do so
because you can only process so much
information visually
so at the end of the day there are
things you're going to miss your brain
has to prioritize
what it pays attention to and we'll talk
about that in a little bit
literally could mean different things
for different people it really could wow
okay this research is showing us
something we didn't think was the case
and that is that we can fail to perceive
major things going on right in front of
our eyes remarks
cognitive psychologist bill schull of
yale university
in contrast with a lot of research on
visual visual perception
these studies are truly surprising for
both scientists and lay people because
they're at odds of how we assumed vision
worked
they go on in this article to say this
research on intentional blindness
has come to the front uh more recently
that work showing that people's ability
to detect unexpected objects to which we
aren't paying attention
raises other questions like how much
visual input can the mind actually
encode consciously
and unconsciously what become
or what brings some visual objects to
conscious awareness
like what makes you pay attention to
certain things versus others
while others pretty much go on unnoticed
what is the fate of information that is
perceived only
unconsciously there's lots of questions
now about well how does your attention
really work what is your brain really
doing
why is it picking out certain
information over other parts
i gotta use this when i when i talk with
my wife because you know i have that
classic thing where it's like can you
please get the butter out of the
refrigerator and you open it up and it's
like i don't see it
you know she'll walk right over and be
like it's right here in the front
you know it's like how do we not see
things
yeah that are right in front of us it's
really amazing so another article
from yale journal of biology and
medicine
was titled the role of attention and
learning in the digital age because
that's what we're facing with now it's
not just inattentional blindness because
we are but now we're faced with all
kinds of digital distractions
so he got to this
section called the cognitive
neuroscience of attention
and i just like to read this section out
of here probably the most critical
element of attention
that is relevant to how information is
processed in digital
environments is restricted capacity
okay humans have only a limited neural
resource
to process the complexity of the
surrounding environment right
moreover there are an infinite number of
ways in which we could
act in any given situation at any given
time
the cognitive ability to allocate our
attention selectively
allows us to prioritize only some
elements of the environment
while filtering out other elements
and now classic example of filtering is
known as the cocktail party effect
do you know what the cocktail party
effect is okay so the cocktail party
effect is
imagine that you are at a party they're
using a cocktail party
and in the party you're talking with a
small group of people
but really there are maybe five or ten
groups of people all throughout the room
okay and as you're in conversation you
pretty much
would think you're only really hearing
the people that you're in the small
group with
but the next thing you know you hear
your name
and it came from across the room why did
you hear your name
that's the cocktail party effect because
your brain
has trained itself to filter for that
piece of information
and so even though it's clear across the
room and you're supposedly actively
listening over here to these group of
people
somebody says your name across the room
and now you're like what
somebody just said my name because
you're tuned into that
so your brain's amazing we call that
also selective hearing
selective hearing
[Laughter]
this was another article i found from
ncbi this is inattentional blindness
what captures your attention
and so uh it's going over
how do we process information it says
most mental processing occurs outside of
conscious awareness
and it makes sense right we know that
our brain is processing
all these different factors in our
environment the amount of information
that can be taken in by our senses
is pretty much limitless you can take in
everything and and you know they've
shown that for example
uh people that have photographic
memories they can go into a room
and it's like their mind takes a picture
of everything in the room
and if you need them to recall some
detail about it they can because they
have the photograph and it's there and
and they know the actor dustin hoffman
he played in a movie called rain man
right did you know that dustin hoffman
actually is able to do the things that
he was doing in rain man
can count cards he can count cards and
matchsticks and
people in a room he's one of those
people that can do that so
for him even though he's like an actor
in a role his mind is capable of doing
those things
have you ever seen those videos of like
those people who can't forget anything
like they literally remember everything
every experience if you say what
happened
what happened february 10th on you know
1965 they'd be like world series this
that
it was like they could recall the
information that's what was what's
really fascinating
the guy that they based the movie rain
man on i don't remember his name
but he has some very unique abilities
one is he's kind of like one of those
people
that you were just describing but like
he can read an entire phone look
and then you tell him a number and he'll
tell you the name of the person
so that's an entire book ability or
it's it's skill i mean what is it like
you need to train for that the only
thing i can think of
is our brain is capable of these things
but because of sin our minds have been
corrupted and so
now we see remnants of what our brain is
capable in certain
people it's like that potential has been
unlocked in them
whereas in most of us it's locked down
it's probably a blessing though that we
can't remember everything you know what
i mean it's like there's things that
everyone's done in their lives that
they're just like
i'd like to forget that yeah and the
same guy that i was talking about the
movie
that they based ring man off of he can
read two sides of a page at the same
time
one eye focuses on one age one page one
eye focuses on another
and he reads the page and very quickly
it's like for him it's like taking a
photograph
wow and it goes on to the next one so
for me i mean seriously i didn't
struggle for like
memorize scripture yeah i mean i mean
seriously i mean like i really want to
get those promises right and it's hard i
mean i really like 10 times i write down
and
i don't know it's hard so like eric
wilson has said on our show
he repeats them out loud the more senses
that you involve in something
the more um able you are to learn it
so if you want to remember the scripture
don't just read it
say it out loud write it down okay
those are senses that you and you're
reinforcing that form of learning over
and over again
and you have to do it multiple times and
you got to practice you know and then
eat it
you lose stuff yeah like daniel
so this goes on to say it says our
senses receive much more information
than what can uh possibly be processed
at one time
so it's reinforcing the you know what
the other two articles were saying
to combat information overload the brain
allows large amounts of information to
enter
almost entirely unassimilated and peels
off just a few pieces of selected
information for closer look
and so your brain is very good at this
like as a master of filtering right
deciding what to focus on the brain
scans about 30 to 40 pieces
of information so sights sounds smells
tactile data and it does this
per second until something catches our
attention all right then our attention
filter selects just a small event
amount of information a process and
anything left over
you know goes in the goes in the memory
bank you know you're not really you know
you're not really thinking about it's
there but you know it's kind of like
okay put that in the file somewhere
the rest of the information information
never reaches your consciousness
it's in there you just don't really get
it and that's what they're getting at
with inattentional blindness
it's those parts of information that
your brain took it all in
but it didn't bring it to your conscious
awareness
unfortunately what they're saying from
this is the brain is a master at
filling in the gaps and compiling an
integrated portrait of reality
based on just a flickering view
so a lot of times we think we have the
whole picture
but it's really our brain that's filling
in the gaps for us
which is why it's important what kind of
information that we take in
when we worked on pseudology and we were
really trying to get to the bottom in
the science of the brain and sort of its
connection with media
it was really interesting to explore
like why does a trailer work
like what's the mechanism that like
everybody's like so it you know you
sometimes we would watch the movies just
to watch the trailers because they were
so like impactful but
we kind of discovered that the brain
does not like incompleteness
and so when it only gets parts of the
story it's wanting to fill in those gaps
and it's like
itching to try and and and get the
complete thing
out of it and that's what the attraction
is and that's why cliffhangers work for
shows
yeah yeah yeah exactly i need to stick
around and and finish this thing why did
i just watch
45 minutes of it you know so
our visual attentiveness is really
shaped by four factors
okay the first one is what's called
conspicuity
that's the degree to which an object or
a piece of information jumps
out to capture our attention and that
falls into two categories
there's sensory and there's cognitive so
sensory refers to the physical
properties of something
so you know like if there's
50 balls in a room okay and they're all
the same color except for one
what it what is your brain going to grab
as a toward it's going to gravitate
toward that one oh that's important
that's
that's different right and so it has a
physical property that makes it
stand out or jump out to you they all
may be white there's a red one there and
your mind's like oh that's red
it becomes very obvious and so when it
comes to
uh sensory things when it comes to
physical properties
your brain looks for physical properties
and say what stands out
okay then there's the cognitive part of
this
so that's the the cocktail party where
you're
you know you're you're filtering out
information it seems like it's a
background but then your brain can pick
something out of the background
that it's uh in tune with like your name
or something
okay so that's the first one it's
conspicuity
the second one is mental workload and
task
interference so unintentional blindness
is more likely to occur in
part of our attention if it is
diverted to a secondary task so like
answering the phone while entering
prescriptions on the computer you know
if you work at a pharmacy
or thinking about dinner plans while
transcribing an order something like
that once you start doing multiple tasks
the same time
then it interferes with your brain's
ability to
process all the information correctly
and that's kind of like a
no duh it makes sense right they say men
are especially bad at this
right like we do not multitask well but
can women really do that
multitask well i mean is it just is it
just we say that but they can't
really like i don't know i kind of
wonder if it's a learned behavior
that's what yeah that's so thinking like
it's not necessarily
well or not it's might be a little
better just because of habit or practice
over the years
it's it's something that at one time i
would say
i could do pretty well but now not so
much
i worked a job um in in ag chemistry
where you know it was a lab they brought
in samples
and on that sample you might have to run
half a dozen tests
it's like okay no big deal there's kind
of a sequence in order that you would do
do things in but what if they bring you
six different samples and they all kind
of bring them pretty close to the same
time
now you have to do all these tests
prioritize what's going on
realize who needs what first and get all
the tests done
and you can't forget any of them right
and somebody's going to be calling you
on the phone so
that was a job where everybody had to be
very good at multitasking
because not only are you running the
samples then you got to go enter data in
the computer
and you've got to answer the phone and
there's all these things going on and if
you make a mistake
people are not happy like you are
costing us money right
so i don't know if that's multitasking
or being efficient
it was multitasking because you are
having to do multiple things at the same
time
test and test and test and test so
you're running multi multi tests
efficiency did play a factor but you're
also multitasking too
so but again it's kind of one thing that
we kind of intuitively know
if we're doing lots of different things
at the same time it's going to affect
our ability to
pay attention because um
just having this conversation with my
mom who's done research on this and she
was just like
you know we need to make sure we
understand what multitasking is it is
very much impossible to
multitask in the sense of doing two
things at the same exact time
what really is happening is someone has
gotten proficient at switching
very quickly there's no like down time
oh let me remember what i need to do
it's like no i can do this then this
then this
one right after the other and that's
that's what makes it so different
yeah so next thing that they put in was
expectations okay expectations have a
powerful effect on our ability to pay
attention and
notice information so
they use the example of drugs if the
drug we are looking for comes in a
carton with a highly
stylized label for example we come to
expect this every
time we get that medication
if a new medicine comes in a similar
looking
carton then our brain will not pay
attention if any
information uh negates our belief that
the new drug is the old one okay so
um this is a well they what they call
this is confirmation bias essentially
um and they sell they say that
experienced health care workers
are actually most prone to this so
if we expect it to be a certain thing
then we kind of dismiss
anything about it that would necessarily
be new
if it looks the same as it did before
because we
it always looks that way right so why
would it be why would it be any
different
is that intentional yeah in production
so like for instance nutella right
when it first came out it had a certain
look i think it was a darker color
because it was like the real thing and
years later it actually started getting
lighter and lighter
turns out they're using different
ingredients but people are still buying
it they love it
is it because they're associating it
with that first product which was higher
quality
all right well the last one on the list
was capacity
and the capacity to pay attention varies
from person to person it's influenced by
age
mental aptitude um also
you know the other things play a factor
like distractions alcohol
drugs fatigue you have all that so
you only have so much capacity to pay
attention to so many things
now based on this this is this is kind
of scary information because you think
about all those people that are like
text
messaging you know while driving i mean
you're doing a very complicated task
that is happening very yes
and it's like your attention already you
know it takes a lot of attention to slip
go through a page change something to
look up something i i've i've driven
next to people and seen them
totally like this like wow
and and what do you miss in that split
second that you take your eyes off the
road
yeah it's not just that it brings me
back to your boat analogy if you get off
course by like a millimeter you're going
to end up somewhere
the road is constantly shifting and
changing you can't stay straight the
whole time yeah else you'll land in a
ditch
what was that nautical term that was
basically like
there's like a nautical term that that
like a v vector i think
veer isn't veer a nautical term
like very severe away yeah but it's like
veer is ever so slight
exactly and over the course of time it
gets you're looking down not paying
attention that you need to turn and it's
a disaster but
interesting you said a phrase like the
brain only has a certain capacity
can you read that again so they're
saying that this
affects our visual attentiveness and
capacity
to pay attention varies from person to
person okay so have you
yeah have you ever heard that
your environment will affect your
um your attention or like anything
having to do with focus like if you're
studying or doing anything like that so
if you're in a room full like if your
desk is full of papers that will affect
how you pay attention
you think it's because you're over
stimulating the brain with all this
other stuff that it can't
directly focus on what you're doing um
uh well i guess it could be um
i guess in thinking of studying and it's
like why do people go to libraries right
because it's quiet yeah you know there's
there's not
you're not surrounding yourself with a
lot of other people that can talk to you
or interfere with you
um when you do when you go to the
library you're you're typically
selecting like
one or two books to focus on you bring
that to a space that you have of your
own
cleaning it's really minimizing the
different distractions that can come
into your life
one of my roommates in college was um he
went into medical school ended up being
an
orthopedic surgeon and this kid i
swear was a unique individual because he
would sit and listen to heavy metal i
mean it wasn't just like
you know rock and roll it was like death
metal
and he'd study biology and i was just
like what
i can't even study and i'm over here in
the corner and i mean he's just like
literally focusing
on it and just reading the pages and
doing the work and just listening to
this crazy sounds in his ears
so a c is a past and you still become
a doctor so this kid literally
showed up at class the minimum
requirement that you could he would take
the take
the test like literally wouldn't study
never saw this guy actually even study
really
top grade the whole time what so i asked
him one time and said you know how is
this even possible like you don't study
like i live with you i know what you're
doing
he said well as a kid i learned to read
things all around me
anytime there was words i read them
cereal boxes i would eat my cereal i'd
read it
and he just developed a real good
reading habit and he had
he wouldn't tell you he had a
photographic member but he said he only
needs to read something once and he's
got it
oh man that's cheating guys watching the
exception is definitely not the rule
yeah right
i have a brother-in-law that was uh that
was that way he would go to class the
bare
minimum and the teachers would try to
like throw in quizzes to like throw him
off he'd always go like ace the test
like no issues it's not fair it's not it
must be nice
so one of the things that is uh
taking and directing our attention these
days is
social media right definitely
is a distracting influence to people and
it
prevents us from paying attention to
sometimes the world around us sometimes
the immediate world around us and we're
going to touch on
what some of those categories might be
we made a documentary on that
called selfie and we would encourage you
to take a look at that
and see what effects social media has
on your life um so a few questions
to stimulate discussion are we paying
attention to our children
you know i think it's kind of a sad
situation that
we've we've sort of backed ourselves
into this
work mode in our culture that it's like
that's top priority and it's like both
parents have to go and work because they
need the boat the car
the you know the nice fancy houses and
all this kind of stuff and then we just
farm the kids off to to day care centers
and and it's really interesting to
observe what happens at those daycare
centers they literally plop them in
front of a tv
and so it's like the tv has now become
the educator of the children
and yeah we as as parents i mean not in
my household i hope that i'm i'm paying
attention to my kids but i think the
majority of households don't
pay attention to their kids yeah i find
that you have to be very intentional
these days because
it's so easy to get distracted by like
your phone for example
you know it's like oh somebody's trying
to get a hold of me or oh there's
another email that come in or a text
message or whatever
and if you think about it you're at work
for
eight hours you see your kids for like
what an hour
maybe two hours in the morning and then
two three maybe four hours at night
you're not spending as much time with
them
throughout the week as you are with
other people and so
when we have that time with them we
really need to focus
on our kids you know we have a certain
window of time that we have influence
over them
and then we can get to um guide them and
shape them
and so i think it's important that we
spay
that we pay special attention to our
children and make sure that we're not
they're not feeling neglected and kids
you know they're what they'll kind of do
is they'll
be like okay well they just don't pay
attention to me they'll just go off and
find something else to do or
not really show as much interest in you
because you haven't shown as much
interest in them
and it happens slowly over time and so
it's kind of a scary thing you know you
wake up one day and it's like i don't
know my kid
so we need to pay attention to our
children i've heard it's also good
practice
when you are hanging out with your
children to individually
kind of hang out with each one and enter
into their world instead of always
pulling them into your world
um so to be intentional to sit down and
say you know like okay
for the next you know hour 30 minutes or
whatever we're gonna do what are you
what would you like to do would you like
to go outside would you like to throw a
ball would you like to do this or that
um and have those children suggest those
things to you
and then they feel that connection to
you you know that's a good point
thinking of
quality over quantity because you could
spend all day with your kid yeah
and nothing was accomplished they don't
feel any closer to you but if you take
that
hour and you really resonate with them
that'll make all the difference in the
world
i mean i remember uh growing up you know
and the uh
elementary school it was maybe in the
middle
uh no high school was called the other
one middle school yeah middle school
but you have a little more freedom you
know and
we didn't have social media right i mean
yeah uh
early 90s you didn't have social media
yeah you play outside
you play outside you hang out with your
friends and stuff like you know we're
talking about the time spending time
with their parents or parents with their
kids
and i didn't see my parents uh
that much you know i didn't spend time
with my parents or maybe they didn't say
just go outside you know whatever but uh
i don't is
you know it's different because you can
be
not having social media you know we talk
about or internet
or the kid they're outside but you don't
spend time with the kids yeah
you don't send me it's not just like
media or something like that i mean
maybe you don't have social media but
the point is that spend time with your
kid you know
yeah yeah how would you feel if you went
and spent time
well like i think that one of the
biggest things i'm looking forward to is
hanging out with jesus
right like how would you feel if you
went to go hang out with jesus and he's
always on the phone like talking to
someone else
you know what i mean you kind of just
feel like oh man i think that's kind of
how our kids would
would feel if we are constantly doing
that to them yeah
so i want to show you guys a video of a
social experiment
on how easy it is to be distracted
and um lose your kid
[Music]
emily is concerned that her husband's
not paying attention to her child at the
park because he's always texting on his
phone
and making phone calls and doing work
through his cell phone
so we're going to be going to the park
today to stalk him see if we catch him
on his phone
and then go try to abduct the child so
what do you think will happen when we go
i think it's possible if you call him
over he's gonna come
and his father's not gonna be paying
attention
so you definitely have a chance of
scooping him up
look he's texting i'm gonna go now
want candy let's go
want some more candy yeah
you call me i'll go get more
let's go oh my god
it's over here i don't have any candy
stay here
what the [__] is wrong with you you're
not paying attention you're sitting
there on the phone not paying attention
where is he that's because you're not
paying attention to him
where'd he go josh
we set you up because i knew you don't
pay attention when you have your son
oh please go on you set you up i saw you
texting so i abducted him with some
candy
thank god come here buddy
you know how to keep an eye on him
because it was just like that i'd looked
at him and
took 10 seconds yeah that's
scary yeah yeah you know it's just just
yeah you know yeah i mean i've
been guilty of that kind of a thing you
know just like you know you're trying to
respond to somebody and you're with your
kids and you're watching them i mean
it's like yeah it just takes a second to
take your eyes off of them
but can you guys relate to the thing a
lot of mothers say that um
oh if it's too quiet something's going
on so you might not be actively
listening but
you kind of you have a sense that my
child is in my presence so the fact that
he was able to let this person walk away
and i don't know how what was the span
of time where he wasn't hearing anything
probably when he finished sending the
text he looks up where's my kid
yeah it wasn't at least in the video
that long of a time that he sat there
you know it wasn't like 15 minutes
later that would have been even more
alarming but how quickly
that can happen oh yeah and if that was
somebody who had nefarious intentions
kid is going in the back of a van yeah
never see him again yeah
i got a bunch of amber alerts yesterday
did you guys get out yeah
you know and i always think too he's
just like oh man
so pay attention to kids not just for
their
safety but also for their well-being for
their spiritual development for your
relationship with them
it's important that we pay attention to
our children
another um category i thought of are we
paying attention to our friends
and family do you keep up do you know
how
people of your circle are doing do you
notice when people are
you know something's off that's not
quite right or they're down or whatever
you know
um keep hitting the social media thing
with kids
you know they can have facebook
depression and as a parent you wouldn't
know it
because it's a there's specific things
that you have to look for and
usually require some kind of clinical
diagnosis but you would think everything
is fine
is everything fine do you check in with
people do you see how they are do you
know like what's going on like your
brothers your mom your parents your kids
your
friends what's going on in their life
you know it's sometimes hard
i think uh especially like you know work
stresses or something you know and
you're just like you know hey do i
do i ask do i maybe not want to know is
something going on at somebody's house
but i think you're right it's like we
should be you know having open dialogue
with those around us and
you know i think i had a friend when i
was in los angeles that ended up
committing suicide
and i hung out with him a couple days
before he did it and
um i would not have known like literally
would not have known
and so i didn't ask i didn't inquire or
anything like that and
and maybe you know i don't know if you
would have been honest and told me but
there's a study that shows that couples
specifically married couples are happier
and make more money in the long
run than single people i wonder if it's
because although
both parties those are single and are a
couple
have work in their lives there's
different priorities for the for the
couple
they also have the elements of family
they're driving each other
possibly spending time with each other
keeping each other balanced versus
the single person may not have that as
frequently so
having that priority um with your family
at all times so even if you have to do
that slight multitask shift focus
not always be focused on work it's still
essential it's so important to
re-prioritize have them
at the center at all times despite
whatever else is going on
have you ever noticed as as sometimes
there's elderly couples and a spouse
dies
and then not long after the other one
passed six two months later
yeah that happens in a lot of cases not
every case obviously but
i think for people who are become alone
like one of the things that keeps them
going there's a few things but one is
having other people around like they
feel like they have some
someone to keep living for
another thing is routine people that
develop a highly structured routine
it helps them um live longer actually
because they're like always there's that
expectation that they're going to do the
same thing over and over again
so i'm going to show you guys another
video where you you look like you were
going to say something
uh yeah kind of interesting what you
were saying like you know hey have you
check your friends or you check your you
know your family you know stuff like
that
uh a couple months ago uh i did this i
don't know if it was
you know a project i don't know i was
just thinking in my mind i was like
you know what i'm gonna be you know on
sundays or something like that i'm gonna
be spending
you know a couple hours of my time to
just to
call my friends you know like a video
call and face facebook you know stuff
like that i mean the people that
i haven't seen you know after high
school you know 20 years
or something like i just see a few
things from
social media what happened but i just
want to call them you know
so i did that maybe like five people you
know
just call them video call and they're
like whoa
hey you know what's up you know and uh
two of them i mean they really you know
they told me like hey you know what you
know after
high school i did this and thanks so
much for calling and i just see your
pictures you know on face and
and social media and thanks so much for
you know
taking the time you know it was the the
friendship there
uh sometimes you think like hey it's
only you know 20 years of i haven't
talked to this guy
why don't you just see him you know or
talk to him it's kind of like you're
going back to the
sure to the last minute you say hey see
you later man you know
so yeah well here's another video
another social experiment i thought it
was really fascinating to see how well
we actually pay attention
to those around us
[Music]
i love my family and we have had a very
amazing life together
a lot of people wish they had family and
they don't have family so i'm thankful
for my family that we have and they're
so supportive of me that's the thing
because i sing
and i'm always out somewhere and they're
always cheering me on okay lauren are
you like a car battery she's a positive
on the negative that's what we joke
about a lot
because it keeps the car going we've
been here together 16 years and i can
tell you i've never been
medical in my life she's so friendly
she's so full of love
she would help a stranger please
stranger out
i know celine since i was 10. we grew up
in the same small city in madagascar
we did a lot of travels together we went
especially to morocco twice together and
we have so many great memories together
i love her
so my niece and i became really close
after a basketball camp that i brought
her to when she was
nine years old and we've been playing
basketball ever since
taught her how to dribble between her
legs taught her how to do the killer
crossover it's really quick
she finally had now she gets me special
we have a special connection through
[Music]
that
oh my god it's lori that's my wife i
walked right by i didn't recognize her
oh my god i didn't pay attention to when
she's there
[Music]
wow total surprise
i had no idea i mean it
she looked my niece it was a little
familiar but i was in a hurry
i'm good
[Music]
because that's heartbreaking to see my
family on the street it makes me realize
how people don't even pay attention to
homeless
it could be anybody it could be it could
be you it could be me
it could be my best friend
[Music]
so
fascinating yes very would you recognize
one of your family members
i mean all those all of those people
probably would have said oh yeah i
probably would right
and they didn't and it just goes to show
even though it's about homeless people
it just goes to show how little
we pay attention and how we could see
our family member
but not see our family member and how
often does that happen
in maybe less dramatic ways in life
well we're seeing people and we're
hearing people
but we're really not with seeing what's
going on and we're really not listening
and so then we miss those
cues that lead to tragic things like
your friend who committed suicide and
you just talked to him a couple days
before
didn't know right so
you know going along with this theme of
paying attention it's important to pay
attention
even to small things little things
because we can miss
so much i think just slowing down
too you know take life a little bit
slower there
just you know i think we're in this rat
race that makes it difficult
and and i also think that that compounds
into a problem if we're spending so much
time on all these other things and we're
so busy and we just have no time for
anything
the person who really gets the short end
of the stick is god
and sometimes we we do not spend time
with him because we have all these other
things going and i like what martin
luther said
you know he's like i have to spend three
hours
plus in prayer because i have so much i
have to do you know
i think also we're all different and i
think uh first we need to pay attention
to ourselves
you know not being selfish but say how
it is
pay attention to ourselves in order to
equip ourselves to pay attention to
others
because some people it's just innate you
know
i have been told that i am more
observant than the average person
but also in my upbringing one of the
first lessons that i remember
learning as a child was always make eye
contact if someone's talking to you if
you see someone if someone's trying to
get your attention
make that eye contact but that's
something that needed to be learned
training so if something isn't doesn't
come natural to you such as being
observant
you know looking at everything around
you then maybe more intentional about
that down the road
but also we've learned now that doesn't
matter how observant you are you still
miss stuff so even
the most observant person needs to pay
attention as well
yeah so next question are we paying
attention to
our community right as christians we
have a responsibility to reach out to
the community
around us right there are needs in our
community there are
i mean the communities are made of
people and that's what we're all about
is trying to
help those people prepare for jesus
coming again
right so what is your community going
through a lot of times
you know for example a church may move
into an area and
they might let's just say start a
program
it doesn't do any good to start that
program unless you know your community
actually
needs that program so it's better to ask
first you know go around ask the
neighbors do surveys whatever
and find out what do they actually need
maybe
um they don't need an after-school
program maybe they really need help with
finances
and so your church would be better
serving those people by holding like a
financial peace seminar or something
instead of having an after-school
program so
find out what the needs of your
community are
so i want to show you guys another video
and it's probably the second to last one
and just again with the theme of paying
attention it's going to be a slightly
different perspective though
this is going to be from a ted talk
and a guy who studies people for a
living as a pickpocket
so hope you haven't seen this before
do you think it's possible to control
someone's attention
even more than that what about
predicting human behavior
i think those are interesting ideas if
you could i mean for me that'd be the
perfect superpower
actually kind of an evil way of
approaching it but for myself
in the past i've spent the last 20 years
studying human behavior from a rather
unorthodox way
picking pockets when we think of
misdirection we think of something as
looking off to the side
when actually it's often that things are
right in front of us there are hardest
things to see the things that you look
at every day
that you're blinded to for example how
many of you still have your cell phones
on you right now
great double check make sure you still
have them on you i was doing some
shopping beforehand
now you've looked at him probably a few
times today but i'm going to ask you a
question about it without looking at
your cell phone directly yet
can you remember the icon in the bottom
right corner
bring them out check and see how
accurate you were
how'd you do show our hands did we get
it
now that you're done looking at those
close them down because every phone has
something in common no matter
how you organize the icons you still
have a clock on the front
so without looking at your phone what
time was it
you just looked at your clock right it's
an interesting idea now i'll ask you to
take that step further with a game of
trust
close your eyes i i realize i'm asking
you to do that while you just heard
there's a pickpocket in the room
but close your eyes now
you've been watching me for about 30
seconds with your eyes closed
what am i wearing make your best guess
what color is my shirt what color is my
tie
now open your eyes by showing hands were
you right
it's interesting isn't it some of us are
a little bit more perceptive than others
it seems that way
but i have a different theory about that
that model of attention
they have fancy models of attention
posner's trendy model of attention for
me i like to think of it very simple
like a surveillance system
it's kind of uh like you have all these
fancy sensories and inside your brain
is a little security guard for me i like
to call him frank
so frank is sitting at a desk he's got
all sorts of cool information in front
of him high-tech equipment
he's got cameras he's got a little phone
that he can pick up listen to the ears
all these senses all these perceptions
but attention
is what steers your perceptions is what
controls your reality
it's the gateway to the mind if you
don't attend to something you can't be
aware of it
but ironically you can attend to
something without being aware of it
that's why there's the cocktail effect
when you're in a party you're having
conversations with someone
and yet you can recognize your name and
you didn't even realize you were
listening to that
now for my job i have to play with
techniques to exploit this to
play with your attention as a limited
resource so if i could
control how you spend your attention if
i could maybe steal your attention
through a distraction
now instead of doing it like
misdirection and throwing off to the
side
instead what i choose to focus on is
frank to be able to play with the frank
inside your head
your little security guard and get you
instead of focusing on your external
senses
just to go internal for a second so if i
ask you to access a memory
like what is that what just happened do
you have a wallet do you have an
american express in your wallet
and when i do that your frank turns
around
he accesses the file he has to rewind
the tape and what's interesting is he
can't rewind the tape at the same time
that he's trying to process new data
i mean this sounds like a good theory
but i could talk for a long time and
tell you lots of things and they may be
true
portion of them but i think it's better
if i tried to show that to you here live
so if i come down i'm going to do a
little bit of shopping just hold still
where you are
hello how are you it's lovely to see you
you did a wonderful job on stage you
have a lovely watch that doesn't come
off very well do you have your ring as
well
good just taking inventory you're like a
buffet it's hard to tell where to start
there's so many great things
hi how are you good to see you hi sir
could you stand up for me please
just right where you are yo you're
married you follow the directions well
that's nice to meet you sir
you don't have a whole lot inside your
pockets anything down by the pocket over
here
hopefully so have a seat there you go
you're doing well hi sir how are you
good to see you sir you have a ring a
watch do you have a wallet on you
i don't uh well we'll find one for you
come on up this way joe
give joe a round of applause come on up
joe let's play a game
pardon me don't think that any of this
clicker anymore you can have that thank
you very much
appreciate that come on up to the stage
joe let's play a little game now do you
have
anything in your front pockets money all
right let's try that
can you stand right over this way for me
turn around and let's see if i give you
something that belongs to me this is
just something uh
a half poker chip hold out your hand for
me
watch it kind of close now this is a
task for you to focus on
now you have your money in your front
pocket here good
i'm not going to actually put my hand in
your pocket i'm not ready for that kind
of commitment
one time a guy had a hole in his pocket
that was rather traumatizing
i was looking for his wallet and he gave
me his phone numbers a big
miscommunication
so let's do this simply squeeze your
hand
squeeze it tight do you feel the poker
chip in your hand would you be surprised
if i could take it out of your hand say
yes
good open your hand thank you very much
i'll cheat if you give me a chance
make it harder for me just use your hand
grab my wrist but squeeze squeeze firm
did you see it go
no no it's not here open your hand see
while we're focused on the hand it's
sitting on your shoulder right now
go and take it off now let's try that
again hold your hand out flat open it up
all the way
put your hand up a little bit higher but
watch it close there joe see if i did it
slowly
it'd be back on your shoulder
joe we're going to keep doing this so
you catch it you're going to get
eventually i have faith in you
squeeze firm squeeze you're human you're
not slow it's back on your shoulder
you're focused on your hand that's why
you were distracted while you were
watching this i couldn't quite get your
watch off it was difficult
yeah you had something inside your front
pocket do you remember what it was
check your pocket see if it's still
there is it still there
oh that's where it was go ahead and put
it away we're just shopping this trick's
more about the timing really
i'm gonna try to push it inside your
hand put your other hand on top for me
would you
it's amazingly obvious now isn't it it
looks a lot like the watch i was wearing
doesn't it
oh thanks but it's only a start
let's try it again a little bit
differently hold your hands together put
your other hand on top
now if you're watching this little token
this obvious has become a little target
it's like a red herring if we watch this
kind of close it looks like it goes away
it's not back on your shoulder it falls
out of the air lands right back in the
hand did you see it go
that's funny you got a little guy he's
union he works up there all day
if i did slowly go straight away it
lands down by your pocket i believe is
it in this pocket sir no don't reach in
your pocket that's a different show
sorry that's rather strange you have
shots for that and
let's show them what that is that's
rather bizarre is this your sir i have
no idea how that works we'll just send
that over there
that's great i need help with this one
step over this way for me
now don't run away you had something
done while your pants pocket i was
checking mine i couldn't find everything
but i noticed you had something here i
feel the outside of your pocket for a
moment
down here i noticed this is this
something of yours or is this
i had no idea that's a shrimp i'm saving
it for later
you've entertained all these people in a
wonderful way better than you know
so we'd love to give you this lovely
watch as a gift
hopefully matches his taste uh but also
we have a couple of other things a
little bit of cash
and then we have a few other things
these all belong to you along with a big
round of applause from all your friends
joe thank you very much
so same question i asked you before but
this time you don't have to close your
eyes
what am i wearing
attention is a powerful thing like i
said it shapes your reality
so i guess i'd like to pose that
question to you if you could control
somebody's attention
what would you do with it thank you
now that we know that he changed shirts
if you watch it again then you'll see
exactly when he changes her it's sort of
like probably winning it up front
i don't know i mean i didn't even see it
but it's like you know when you watch a
show and then you watch it again you
watch it third time when you're reading
when you're reading god's word like
you're seeing different things at
different
times yeah wow yeah i think that's
what's scary
is this like you know this is clearly
something that we know
exists right this is real this is this
is
you know this this is something that you
can put your fingers on and say this is
happening over here now what if somebody
maliciously wanted to use this
technology that's where it gets scary i
think for me
i mean yeah like you were saying taking
the time when you read the word of god i
mean different
you know many times i mean you get
different information but from the same
i mean like this guy i mean
you know he changed the whole offer like
a win i mean i was just looking at it
yeah yeah you know so did you catch that
like when he did it no no no did you
notice that he did do it early
no or when tilly asked the question no
no before he asked it
um i did notice that his shirt was
outside of his pants yeah that's why you
saw that
that was the only thing but color
changed and then no tie
that until he acts like so there's a
certain point though that you're like
wait wait a minute he had to do that
when did he do it he didn't do that i
mean like run it back and forth okay so
my guess
is when he brought the man up front i
was walking yes while he was
walking up to the front and handing off
the clicker and all that he's
simultaneously
undoing his time our focus is on oh is
he tricking those people as he's talking
to them
he's almost using an audio cue as well
like it's a trick within a trick
yeah exactly so he's not taking anything
from those people he's actually changing
his clothes
but we have no idea what's going on wow
so how he could change his
i mean he had a jacket yeah well the
jacket didn't change
so he just pulled it later yeah
magic right when you really sit and
distill down what magic is
illusion magic is this is true yes yes
illusion like magic is as in like
carnival type you know like somebody up
there just doing cards or something like
this but they're just diverting your
focus and your attention so they can do
something over here yeah
distracting we pay attention there
yeah we do have to pay attention so
we'll go back to your thing about
community we can use that as an
illustration
because we were so we were so focused on
one thing that wasn't particularly bad
so when you think of community you're
focusing on that one family
that needs help but what is being
neglected so actually
being intentional about changing up your
focus
within community reaching the different
needs will help
not neglect a certain area yeah exactly
um yeah we have to pay attention to
multiple things for sure
yeah and and it certainly makes sense
for multiple eyes to be on
multiple you know to be on those things
so that everybody is
giving input like oh but did you catch
that or did you catch that
you should be an expert in this keith
right having four kids i should be but
my wife's probably better at it than i
am are we paying attention to our
broader world
right we live in a world where lots of
things are going on and
and even though we have like all these
news networks and
you know social media which isn't
exactly entirely reliable for news
uh fake news spread six times faster
than real news
so even though you have all of these
outlets and all this information again
it goes back to you can only pay
attention to so much
right and so even though all the
information is there it's available you
have the internet you can google things
you can watch things you can
you can take it all in you can't really
take it all in there's only so much
you can focus on so we have to really be
very intentional what we pay attention
to and very specific
um after seeing that video uh
i hope that we have your attention
right and that because we talk about uh
paying attention to things in the media
that's what that's what we do you know
did you guys know this or did you know
that and we're trying to get you to see
things that are there that
weren't entirely obvious right and so
that's part of our work is helping you
know what to pay attention to and bring
that out to the forefront of your
consciousness
so are you paying attention to the
broader world jesus said this in matthew
25 13 he says watch therefore for you
know neither the day nor the hour
which the son of man is coming jesus is
telling us
pay attention right be alert be watchful
he told us many things would happen in
the last days and that some of those
things
would be designed to deceive us in fact
multiple times jesus said
in matthew 24 do not be deceived why
because the possibility exists for
deception
and on a big broad grand scale
so jesus has warned us ahead of time
i can think of three types of deception
that i'd like to talk about just briefly
as we're
coming to the end of this program
one is self one is societal and the
other's supernatural
okay start with self-deception the bible
says for sin
taking occasion by the commandment
deceived me
and by it killed me sin
is deceptive it is self-deceptive
right um the bible says
in jeremiah 17 9 it says that
the heart is deceitful above all else
and desperately wicked who can know it
so the way i like to rephrase that is
more than anything in this world your
heart will lie to you
it's the greatest liar like your your
heart
because it's influenced by sin and satan
but i mean it'll lie to you better than
other people will so are you
experiencing some self-deficit
self-deception
we um we did this program recently with
the held singers
and one of the books uh that they were
recommending for people who had
mental health struggles was
a book called telling yourself the truth
because there are people
that are not very good at telling
themselves the truth that's right about
themselves
i'm worthless nobody loves me i could
never do that right we tell ourselves
all these kind of lies
and it's and that's what sin does it
causes us
to be self-deceived i like that dove
commercial
where they'd ask people to describe that
oh yeah yeah and then they were you know
that'd have been a great video
as they're more ugly but like when they
when someone else would describe them
they'd be beautiful
you know yeah
so another category societal deception
the bible says in matthew 24
for false christs and false prophets
will rise and show great signs and
wonders to deceive
if possible even the elect and this kind
of borders on the supernatural as well
but the purpose of this deception is to
deceive society at large to deceive
the whole world that's what revelation
13 talks about
is that deception is coming to the whole
world
we have to pay attention we have to know
like what is that deception how is it
going to happen
will i recognize the signs when it does
happen
and to do that we have to study our
bibles which means we have to direct our
attention
and focus there know what it says
otherwise we're sitting ducks right
even the elect they can't be deceived
could be
yeah last category supernatural
deception
it says this in revelation 19 20 then
the beast was captured
and with him the false prophet who
worked signs in his presence by which he
deceived those who received the mark of
the beast
and those who worshipped his image these
were cast alive into the lake of fire
burning with brimstone
the audio visuals at the end of time
will be
overwhelming right they will be designed
they are specifically designed
to deceive and mislead you you're going
to see miracles
you're gonna see you know like this says
signs and
and the heavens signs and the earth
you're gonna see
all kinds of things that are
only there to lead you astray that's
what satan does that's why
i i believe it says if it does not speak
according to the law and to the
testimony it is because there's no light
in it like
you have to kind of constantly balance
what you're perceiving or anything
through that that biblical filter yeah
and so media is a is a
is almost a bit of a test to the broader
things that are going to be happening
right if we can't discern what it is
that's
being put before our eyes on a daily
basis how are we going to discern
greater and grander deceptions that are
happening in the world
so important that you learn to discern
and pay attention to the media that's
coming into your life so that you can
filter that properly yeah we have a
responsibility but there's also another
party involved
you're talking about how do we pay
attention to the world around us we have
our kids our community and the whole
world it's nearly impossible
scientifically it's impossible
but yet jesus says in matthew
28 he gives specific instructions verse
go ye therefore and teach all nations
that's the entire world so he wants us
to
pay attention and i think he did that
no even knowing the science because he
wants us to include him
in that action there's a couple of
things here one i think
that the bible is there for us
specifically so we know
it helps us learn how to filter and
specifically what we know so we can be
equipped on what to pay attention to
absolutely secondly you have god has
given us his spirit
also to prompt us and cue us in
at the right time at the right place so
that we know oh yeah
that's something i should pay attention
to and it brings to our mind
the appropriate um thing so it's like
it's as an active agent in helping us
filter
but we need that divine help like you're
saying for sure
so i want to show you this video mikey
showed this to me and it's an example of
some of the deceptions that are coming
as we get closer and closer to the end
of time
okay so here we go this is a guy who is
explaining things from the bible but
he's then also mixing in
um his interpretation of prophecy and
also the apocryphal books and all kinds
of stuff
and these people who are left behind
will see my salvation that's jesus
yeshua
and the end of my age they will see the
people who had been taken up
the wise virgins earlier
and who haven't tasted death from their
birth that's the first fruits translated
ones
those who reside in the earth this is
those who reside in the heart of the
earth
that would be dead people will be
changed and converted to a different
spirit
we're going to have dead people come
back to life but it's not the
resurrection of the last trumpet though
daniel 12 2 makes a first a version of
this
then evil will be erased and grief
extinguished faith will flourish because
there's a revival going on
when you have your dead grandmother
walking into a room with your lukewarm
family and she's going to talk about
jesus
your family will all be saved for that
relative of yours who committed suicide
30 years ago
maybe she'll come back and she'll
explain what happened
um so you hear what this guy is teaching
yeah he's saying no saying a lot of
things i'm going to submit this is false
teaching okay
i'm going to clear that up right from
the get-go false teaching but he's
saying
oh yeah your dead relatives are going to
come back and teach you about jesus
uh and he got it from the bible yeah
yeah he's saying he got it from the
bible it was a huge
uh revival there but we need to
understand what the bible says
about those that are dead the dead know
not
anything right so let's go over a couple
of scriptures
and when they shall say to you seek unto
them that have
familiar spirits and unto wizards that
mutter and peep
our peep and that mutter should not a
people
seek unto their god for the living to
the dead
so if you if you really think about that
scripture it's saying no wait a minute
why would you seek out the the dead why
would you seek out a wizard why would
you seek
under seek those that have familiar
spirits when you can
seek god god has given us all the wisdom
that we need he's given us all the
answers in his word
we don't need to go to the dead for
those answers
why is that you know this is this is
israel is talking to israel
they were forbidden to communicate with
the dead
i mean it was a very stiff penalty and
it's
completely out of character god is a god
of patterns he's not about throwing
curveballs at his people
in the entire bible you never hear of
someone being raised from the dead to go
and give a message to anyone
in fact we see from amos it's in chapter
he says the lord god does nothing unless
he reveals it to his servants the
prophets that's right so he reveals
everything he's going to do everything
you need to know
through those that are living through
the prophets and of course his word is
living as well i think the state of the
dead is important to understand
due to the final things that are going
to transpire in our earth and if you're
you're opening
your belief to okay well people can come
back to the dead
and and give me some sort of message
what if it was an apostle
you know what i mean what if like an
apostle showed up and was like well you
know there's all these translations and
they totally messed up what
what i wrote back there this is what i
really meant and
and now they're reinterpreting what the
context of that bible it would be
superseding
god's written word and then like how
would you ever know what was true that's
right
right there's no safeguards there um
so yeah communicating with the dead
serious matter you were executed in
israel
if you were caught doing that uh why
i believe because it's a counterfeit
for the gift of prophecy and it is a
counterfeit for the truth it's a
counterfeit for communication
god said no no i already have ways to
communicate with you
you don't need this other form of
communication in fact this is trying to
impersonate my voice
yeah and and and we know that the devil
can impersonate
people because of the story of samuel or
the story of seoul
conjuring up samuel right we know that's
not samuel but
it appeared to soul in the way that saul
thought it was samuel
so another verse this comes from
ecclesiastes chapter 9 it says for the
living know
that they shall die but the dead know
not
anything neither have they any more
reward for the memory of them it's
forgotten
so i think this verse gives us a very
strong clue
it says that don't know they don't know
anything and if they don't know anything
they don't have any information for uri
they can't
because they don't know anything which
means if you're getting information from
the dead
um you're not getting it from the dead
you're getting it from another source
because they don't have any information
and um
if someone dies and uh goes to heaven
and come back
that's not dead that's just living
somewhere else right
yeah the bible calls us mortals right
immortal means subject
to death it says that we put on
immortality at the second coming and it
says that the only one who is immortal
is god
so if we just continue to live somewhere
else
right after we're dead right then we
also destroy
the metaphor of the bible that it's
trying to teach us that
we are dead to sin right because
what would it mean if you were well
you're you're not really dead to sin
because nobody really dies and you're
just living somewhere else so
you're just living to sin somewhere else
like it completely destroys
what that means uh if we don't
understand it from the biblical
perspective so
being dead to sin means dead
no longer coming up again no law it
doesn't get raised it doesn't
speak it doesn't live it doesn't breathe
nothing
it's dead and that's how we need to be
to sin is
it needs to be completely not a part of
our experience
anymore so
i want to wrap this up
second to last slide here with a quote
quote i seen a long time ago
and i went to look up who said it and
actually there was a little more there
than i had realized
it says this is stephen archavia says we
see the world
not as it is but as we are
or as we are conditioned to see it
scary thought right yeah we
can only pay attention to so much that's
why we need the bible that's why we need
the spirit of god
but we also need to recognize that about
ourselves that we can only filter
so much and so we have to be very
intentional on what we pay attention to
so my admonition to you is pay attention
to prophecy
pay attention to people right the
greatest tragedy in this world would be
to
ignore both and not be ready for the
second coming
or bring anybody with you that's really
sad
it is very sad and so as we close this
program
um i just have one question for you
that are watching it's the same one from
the videos that we've seen with
apollo robbins what am i wearing
[Music]
well any uh any closing thoughts from
you guys
uh about attention or anything that
we've talked about today before we wrap
up this show
i think that um you know when just
looking at some of the stories in the
bible like peter
keeping his eyes on jesus and you know
we're all going to go through a storm
we're all going to go through this rough
time and if the end of the world is like
what the bible says like no other time
that's been around
the only surety that we have is to keep
our eyes on jesus
and so i think you know the devil's the
master at
uh uh magical you know attentions and
illusions and so uh you know
we'll find ourselves sinking if we
cannot stay connected to christ and so i
think
you know keep your eyes focused on him
and uh he will reveal to you and speak
to your hearts
yeah i believe that we need to that will
check what we
what we believe because sometimes you
know oh we have the faith
growing up let me tell you that faith
was your parents faith
what about your faith you know you get
up in the morning you
you build up your faith it's not like
hey
i'm gonna call my pastor yeah hey hey
how do you answer this day no let's
build out your faith and let's focus
what we're living and
and i believe that we're gonna be
passing the test you know let's do it
that way
yeah well i guess
my last thought is uh no pressure
you know what i mean like we all make
mistakes we're all growing
i find so much comfort in the story of
saul
who turned into paul um on the road to
dimax
damascus he was seeing the world through
his conditioning
through his lens and god had to what
drop the scales from his eyes
but god didn't just leave him there he
surrounded him with a community
community of believers people to hold
him accountable and him to hold other
people accountable
so just to to keep that in mind as we go
through life to
be intentional have god
on the throne of your heart for sure
that will definitely help
you navigate through this life and um
so that we're not among the number that
is deceived in the end times
all right well we hope you've enjoyed
this program this has been another
episode of led live
and uh don't forget to like comment
subscribe and also share this video with
your friends and family
and we hope to see you on the next one
you can catch every episode on friday at
noon
and we hope to see you next friday
take care
[Music]
i am the god of the new
i love world i love it i mean i can't
watch
enough of this the dualist who they say
can speak with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation at a local
school and concern from parents the
death note is derived from a japanese
animated show
the girl told authorities she got the
idea from a cartoon network show
mom it's mr sadie i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you